can you name me a cast member from
beverly hills 90210 ashton kutcher is at
it again when it comes to his kutcher
kitchen talks that's pretty good stuff
on tuesday the actor posted this video
of his wife mila kunis cracking up while
quizzing her and their friend vitalik
butterin on these pop culture questions
hey did you tell it who invented goop
and what is it
uh sergey brin and larry page
vitalik can you name me a cast member
from beverly hills 90210 wait wait
nano210 is that like us some kind of
basic manufacturing
[Music]
pop culture isn't the only topic ashen
has quizzed the actress on over the
weekend he tested mila's knowledge on
cryptocurrency and the meaning of
blockchain
hey babe yeah
what's uh crypto it's digital currency
hey hey babe yeah what's blockchain
it's like what information stored on so
like it's you know
what information is stored on
in june the actress appeared on conan
o'brien and revealed she actually spent
most of the pandemic learning about nfts
and cryptocurrency and i felt like it
was a very masculine um
area like everybody that i knew that
knew anything about it at the time was
always a man and i was like
it's gonna be that hard
and um
and you know it was the pandemic and so
i just deep dived into it and surrounded
myself with two incredibly smart women
that know everything about it that you
know started libra for facebook and
whatnot
and educated myself on on crypto
ashton's videos also feature a plug for
mila kunis's new nft animated series
stoner cats
[Music]
[Music]
mila also explained on conan why this
series is different from anything she's
ever done i decided to deep dive into
nfts and so through the pandemic created
a form of entertainment called stoner
cats that we're releasing in a couple
weeks that is an nft and you can buy
such stoner cats and then that is your
token to then watch a five minute long
piece of entertainment and on top of
being a busy actress she and ashton are
also busy parents to their six-year-old
daughter wyatt and four-year-old son
dimitri in 2017 mila told et what it's
like balancing a career and two children
i think i'm a little bit less
stressed over what to anticipate i think
you're still stressed out and there's
still like the idea of the guilt of
leaving your kids but you know that
they'll they'll be okay because i've
already done it once and my kid doesn't
resent me and so i was like okay so i
think i can do this um i also needed to
enlist help